let's talk a little bit about the fact
that we still have a hundred year global
pandemic going on in the United States
and many states are improving while many
states are worsening in terms of the
spread we will see what effect the
protests have on spread of the virus
it'll take about ten days to know for
sure
but I wanted to let you guys know
something that maybe won't will not
surprise some of you which is that dr.
Anthony Fauci has now confirmed that
Donald Trump no longer speaks to him
very much and that he doesn't speak to
really any of the doctors on the
coronavirus task force now why wouldn't
this surprise you well if you know Trump
it wouldn't surprise you but five or six
weeks ago I came to you and I said
Donald Trump is now transitioning to we
are no longer going to talk about
coronavirus as a medical event we are no
longer talking about coronavirus as a
medical problem we're going to shift to
we being Trump we're going to shift to
round tables with CEOs about how much
we're reopening and how many loans we've
dispersed and yada yada yada dr. Anthony
Fauci on the coronavirus task force is
the top infectious disease doctor in the
United States and we as a country
started to see less and less of him
weeks ago dr. pouchy
now has done a number of interviews
recently and in one interview with stat
news said something incredibly revealing
but not altogether shocking doctor foul
she was asked does the president talk to
you about the vaccine work often and
foul cheese answer was no we used to
have task force meetings every single
day including Saturday and Sunday and
about 75% of the time after the task
force meeting we would meet with the
president so I was meeting with him four
times a week back a month or so ago but
as you probably noticed that the task
force meetings have not occurred as
often lately and certainly my meetings
with the president have been
dramatically decreased now there are
going to be right-wingers and trumpets
who say this makes sense this makes
sense the problem is going away the
problem being coronavirus so of course
you have fewer meetings the problem is
that that's not based in reality look at
the trend lines in the United States
cases and deaths have slowly declined
over a 10
period but we are often still finding
20,000 22,000 new cases in a single day
in terms of deaths
fortunately the trendline is down but we
still regularly have 1500 deaths in a
single day from coronavirus so nothing
is over this may end up merely being a
warm-up for wave 2 in the fall which
could be even worse it could be not as
bad we don't know we might not really
even have a break
between the two waves and indeed it
seemed like the breaking point for
Donald Trump was that just disastrous
shameful press briefing in April where
Trump wondered aloud about injecting
bleach and rubbing alcohol into the body
and the coronavirus press briefings were
already starting to wane then and now
it's over and doctor foul Chi has barely
any contact with Donald Trump now
there's some aspect of if I don't look
at it if I don't talk about it it
doesn't exist it's like a hear no evil
see no evil sort of thing there this is
kind of a weird direction to go but
there's something called object
permanence and child development people
will know about this already and this is
a big milestone for little kids as
babies develop there's a phase where if
you take a ball and you hide it the baby
doesn't know that the ball continues to
exist even if you've hidden it behind
your back and at some point I can't
believe this is what how we're analyzing
a president at some point in child
development developing children realize
even if I can no longer see the ball the
ball still exists they can hold the idea
of the ball in their mind and they
continue to understand that just because
you don't see the ball doesn't mean it
has disappeared from existence
Trump's strategy is like that of a baby
pre development of object permanence I
won't talk about it I won't look at it
it's like it doesn't exist and Trump had
this idea pretty early on
remember with testing Trump knew early
on if we do more testing we're gonna
find more cases let's keep our case
numbers low by not doing a lot of
testing that of course backfired so then
we get to a separate question which is
does Trump even believe experts who come
to
with information that he admittedly
doesn't even want to be given not really
Donald Trump believes he knows more than
his generals and his doctors and more
than anybody so the benefit to meeting
with the experts is limited by the fact
that Trump thinks he knows more than
them anyway
but regardless dr. Anthony Fauci no
longer getting much face time with
Donald Trump not a big surprise I would
love it if doctor foul Chi did regular
briefings himself I wouldn't even be
opposed to the CDC being part of them
like dr. Redfield I know he's kind of a
trump tool but without Trump hovering in
the background hinge forward at the hips
and swiveling as he often does during
during the the briefings up I think
doctor foul Qi and dr. Redfield together
could give us a lot of really valuable
information Burks you know remains a
question mark in terms of her just blind
loyalty to Donald Trump but it would be
great to do it like other countries do
it get the politicians out let's get a
briefing from medical experts period
we're not getting that either
unfortunately follow the David Pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
for continued coverage of all of today's
stories and while you are there follow
my personal Instagram not very political
many elements of recreation and
gardening on my personal Instagram may
be a good respite from consistently
horrible news that we are facing today I
am David Pakman on Instagram one of our
sponsors is privacy calm they're giving
you $5 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure
but also to take control of your
finances you can create up to 12 of
these virtual credit cards a month you
can set spending limits you can freeze
them you can delete them anytime you
want so when you do this it means you're
not going to be charged when you don't
want to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman